[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
today what is up guys i'm kim BHT here
okay so there's this rumor floating
around confirmed at some various levels
by some pretty reliable sources of the
iPhone 12 not coming with a charger or
headphones at all in the box when they
come out in September this year now to
be clear I think there are way more
interesting other rumors about the
iPhone 12 floating around out there
right now but this is the one that's
gotten the most interesting reactions
because it is so polarizing one way or
the other and I don't usually do this
but I kind of want it let's just assume
this rumor is true because I want to go
over those two different reactions
because they're so fascinating to me
right now
so reaction number one which is probably
the first one that popped up into your
head which is what the iPhones not going
to ship with a charger that seems
ridiculous like that's that's ridiculous
even to Apple levels of ridiculous like
we've seen them do some pretty out-there
questionable stuff in the past like the
headphone jack the the laptop port
situation all kinds of things and even
maybe getting rid of the headphones in
the box we could understand what the
charging cable and the power brick
they're like the only necessary
accessories those are the things you
have to have in a box like that would be
like shipping a car with no wheels or
like a computer with no power cable I
don't know it just seems ridiculous that
you'd be able to buy something
especially that expensive and it has
some battery out the box sure so you can
use it and set it up but then as soon as
it dies you would have to spend extra to
get it working again so it just
optically it just looks like pure greed
removing something from the box that's
always been there classic Apple creating
a problem and then selling you the
solution it'll probably be another 20 30
bucks to go get that charger after you
need it actually I think I even said
this on Twitter but I was like I don't
think we've ever seen that before have
we ever ever seen a phone ship without a
charger in the box I don't think we've
ever seen that the char
is necessary but then here is reaction
number two yeah whatever
matter-of-fact good the iPhone doesn't
actually really need to ship with a
charger anymore there's already about
five different chargers sitting around
most houses anyway and hey when I get a
new phone usually the things that I
leave in the box are the paperwork and
then the default headphones and charger
because I have my own now not everybody
has my situation obviously but the point
is most people buying an iPhone already
have an iPhone charger that's as good as
the one that they were going to include
in the box anyway but then on top of
that at the iPhones scale which is huge
the e-waste savings would be absolutely
massive there's actually a great article
I already tweeted by dieter at the verge
it's link below where they go deeper
into this but basically they spoke with
the CEO of ankor who notes that chargers
built into the box that people end up
throwing away are a gigantic source of
e-waste and if you include smartphones
and tablets and laptops and power drills
even basically all these built-in
chargers when they get thrown away
you're probably looking at 300,000 tons
of e-waste per year tons 300,000 tons of
waste every year so the iPhone shipping
without a power brick that most people
already have would take a pretty big
chunk out of that that's just facts and
then you know what to take it a step
further efficiency also goes way up
because now instead of having to ship
the phone and the earpods and the
charger in the box really all you have
to ship to people is the phone and a
little bit that paperwork and the
iPhones box is already one of the
smaller boxes in the industry year after
year but getting rid of those
accessories could cut the footprint
basically in half making it one of the
smallest meaning they can fit more on
every truck and on every plane and again
at that scale that means real
environmental impact plus how Apple
would that be right this is our this is
our thinnest box ever so I you know what
good riddance it would be a better
smartphone world if Apple stopped
shipping the charger okay so in reality
my take is I'm actually somewhere in
between these two places because it is a
little bit
more nuanced than that obviously if they
just remove the charger from the box
that would have been nice to have that's
just gonna seem like a negative but
there are some other things that could
also happen at the same time this is
pretty dynamic what if they're able to
adjust the price of the iPhone see
naturally one of the most popular
reactions - they're not going to ship it
with the charger and headphones was okay
well then you better not charge me the
same price as the phone that came with
those things so if we look up here the
typical basic charger on Amazon right
now with a brick would cost about 15
bucks
that's about equal to what Apple was
gonna ship so you take 15 bucks off the
price of the iPhone now you're at nine
hundred eighty five and then a typical
basic pair of headphones in the box if
you actually try to get those from Apple
right now they'll charge you 30 bucks
obviously they're not worth that much
but for the sake of argument go ahead
and take 30 more bucks off of the price
of the iPhone and now you're down to 955
now if you're thinking about what Apple
might do when seeing that you think
maybe they would just round it back up
to a thousand right how many customers
were we gonna have at 950 that we
wouldn't have at a thousand not that
many right but then again Apple has
lowered the price of the iPhone before
the iPhone 11 you might not remember but
very recently the iPhone 10 are launched
at 750 bucks then the next year the
iPhone 11 launched at 700 so there is
precedent for it Apple has lowered the
price of the iPhone before and then I
think it would make it a bit more
tolerable if they also offer on top of
that a discount for people who do want
to add back new pair of headphones or a
new charging brick to the purchase of
their new iPhone so really this would be
more like shipping a camera without the
lens and if you've ever bought a DSLR
you know most of them ship without any
lens even though a lens is a necessary
accessory for the camera to be useful at
all and that's because most people
buying one already have the lenses that
they're going to use or if they don't
they can get a discount on a basic kit
lens that can come with it to get you
started
just like Apple could offer a discount
on a basic basic charger that they
include the iPhone but you know just
like the people who already have like
five or six fancy lenses that they're
gonna use with the new DSLR there's
gonna be people who buy the new iPhone
that already have much nicer chargers
than the one Apple is gonna ship with
the box like a fast charger for example
or a wireless charger so those people
don't need the kit lens in the DSLR box
and those people don't need the built-in
slow charger that they're just gonna
throw away and waste in the iPhone box
so yeah that's that's really it cuz at
the end of the day I think the most
interesting part of this is how is Apple
gonna spin it because you know Apple
people are always sitting waiting to
write that negative headline about what
Apple's gonna do and there's also people
waiting to write that positive headlines
so the question is we've seen Apple
basically conduct a master class over
the years and tilting the way people
view their products through different
lenses so how are they gonna do it with
this like we saw the the headphone jack
a couple couple years ago it was one of
those things where it seemed pretty
ridiculous that Apple was gonna get rid
of like a simple small super useful port
and there are still people to this day
who think that's ridiculous but just a
year or two after all these major
companies were making fun of them for it
they were all copying them and now today
it's hard to find a phone with a
headphone jack that's comparable to the
iPhone not saying that's good or bad but
that's a very similar situation so I
think there's two ways that this could
go number one is Apple doesn't say
anything about it at all
they don't even mention it on stage they
don't talk about it figure they're sort
of trying to avoid another Pro stand
moment on stage the VESA mount adapter
will be $1.99 and the pro stand $9.99
and like the mac pro they'll all be
available in this in the fall huh like
who would want to relive that again by
saying there's no charger in the box so
they don't talk about it at all
it starts to ship and then it slowly
gets uncovered by customers and then
then you start to see probably a lot of
headlines about how Apple didn't mention
that which is why I think number two is
actually more likely I think they just
go straight at it from the environmental
angle and this is something not everyone
even cares that much about or notices
but I don't know if you've watched every
keynote but lately Apple every time they
unveil a new hardware product will
always have a slide about this which is
how environmentally
friendly that they're saying their
manufacturing process is it's always
every year right before they get to the
price they always show this slide so you
could see them really leaning into it
you know with going the next level and
not including the unnecessary charger
and cables in the box and saving
thousands of tons of e-waste in a single
year during the process like you can see
the the Apple bloggers writing defending
that right now if Apple really fully
truly cared deeply about you know the
environmental impact they would better
support user repair or or here's a crazy
idea
make the iPhone USB type-c so we don't
need two different types of chargers
every time but you know that's that's
probably a whole different video but
that that is that's my guess for how I
think Apple would be able to spin not
shipping the accessory they've always
shipped with the iPhone the only one
that's actually necessary to use it with
the phone this year now one last point
made in an article by mg Siegler also
linked below in case the question is why
didn't they do it last year or why are
they picking this year to transition the
iPhone to not having a charger is this
just a greedy 2020 move is this a
margins thing is this a 5g modems in the
new iPhone will cost more so they need a
way to make those margins back what what
is it about this year and I think the
answer might also include that the next
next iPhone the iPhone 12s or 13
whatever it ends up being in 2021 is
rumored to not have any ports at all
it's rumored to be the completely port
lists no lightning no USB C no port all
Wireless iPhone and so this might be a
move just one year earlier to get people
used to the idea of not having a charger
in the box so that the next year one the
incredibly premium port list iPhone that
is Apple's goal finally ships they used
to it already
something to think about but either way
it's all this is all the rumor we're
talking about like I said I generally
don't do this talking extensively about
something that might not even happen but
this is something I'm going to be paying
attention to and maybe you can leave
your thoughts below on what you think
Apple's move should be
for the iPhone that comes out this year
again will they spin it
how will they defend not having a
charger in the iPhone 12 box let me know
what you think thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one peace